we're here today to get face tattoos not
like face face tattoos but like
portraits of each other spaces on the
other spot we've been together worth
like about five years married for four
and a half of them why not just commit
to a lifetime of like our youngest and
best selves yeah on each other's bodies
forever it's unusual certainly but I
think it's kind of a cool extension of
our existing commitment to each other
and if for whatever reason that change
down the road lasers
[Music]
hey I'm zillion we're here at the Warren
this is my shop and I've been tattooing
for about 17 years now I am a pretty
versatile artist my strength would be
portraits or realism there's just
something about faces that when you can
capture somebody's face in their
expression that it's kind of a special
thing so it's just something I've always
been drawn to people worry about who
would if they break up but I think
tattoos are very much bookmarks of
moments in your life and regardless of
what happens to them this is a big part
of their life so I think it's cool are
you guys seeing about Whitney's I was
kind of leaning more towards my shoulder
area somewhere in this real estate yes
yeah kind of I'm on the fence but I'm
open to like placing it in different
areas and we can stencil you in a couple
places you see what it feels right if
that's okay yeah
you're going to go first yeah yeah I
don't know do you feel weird about that
that's true I almost feel like I'm like
evil twin ropes or something that's
growing up you guys gonna move it I like
that so much better
oh but I love it perfect
[Music]
every time y'all got the song is good
together
[Music]
so weird is eerie because it looks like
me so much but it's also just sort of
weird to see my face on your body and
know that it's never going anywhere
[Music]
I think the sound of the machine is
actually very soothing so it just
becomes like a meditative state
eventually we're all done time for you
guys to get to take a look oh my god
I'm not ready yet you go forever all
right mom and a trip it's happening whoa
oh my gosh it's like frightening how
much prettier I am as a tattoo
I hate me the yeah holy crap that like
is so awesome that looks just like my
face shocker a happy note can you
believe it it works are you ready
are you excited yeah I am oh my god it's
you look how excited you are to live
high on forever doing it I was like a
little I hate this but actually like
makes me excited you excited on my arm
like you look so happy to be here I mean
it's like you've made this even better
looking I hope you guys make good
pictures huh I also feel like I'm gonna
be less inclined to get mad at you
sometimes you look so happy to hear that
she's already paying off
eating other people should do this yes
absolutely I mean like how well this
turned out
hey do you wanna you wanna make out
anything like ya know poop that stings
too much about ready for this sort of
repair weirdness someone gets in
[Music]
Oh
[Music]